you ask for your phone don't happen here
sometimes the enemies drag make a call
so I have my friends and my dad here in
the audience tonight and I said I'm
going on Conan tomorrow you all want to
come and this is the response I got are
you kidding definitely without a doubt
or a second thought
all in caps and then Conan is God to me
in my family
he gives us redheaded pale skinned
people hope
[Applause]
all right there there there I was hoping
they were gonna say we love his comedy
no he gives us ready tell people hope
that's right we mutation exactly
mutation exactly so so much to talk
about first of all you had two Oscars by
the age of 30 crazy it took me till I
was 40 to get two Oscars and I think and
they cost a lot yeah so much cost me
$600 no the two Oscars by 30 and such an
incredible achievement and then I was
remembering that just before all that
happened for you you had been on Beverly
Hills 90210 I did see while I was
watching Beverly Hills I was getting no
I was getting a little older at that
point it got creepy you know when a guy
my age who was watching he's watching
Beverly Hills 9:02 honey who might have
been a Luke Perry groupie and let me
just say I was on I know - I know and
the eighth season when no one watched it
anymore and Luke Perry was long gone
right so I was fired off the show at
that point no you know we've devastated
he was like that horrified because the
show was instated I'm thinking no one
watches the show anymore and I got fired
off of the show that no one watches
house right yeah and so so you went
right from that and I think was soon
afterwards you did boys don't cry right
yes I had sign on to a two-year contract
with 92 when I got fired 13 episodes in
of the first year and two months later
after I got fired I got boys don't cry
that is sweet I mean revenge usually
doesn't come that quickly in this I
looked at it as like a silver lining
like the you know it's always such a
reminder when something bad happens that
there's something else that could be
looming around the corner but right
revenge can work - yeah I have an evil
heart so that's how I look at it you got
sweet revenge
you